[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
government work I'm retired
I understand pain yeah
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real peace peace
and I'm starting to believe
they see you as one of us now this is
where I'm supposed to be
please
what happens here happens in many
accounts the mafia
there's like cancer
[Applause]
no cue
who said you could come here
you should stay out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing
this goes to level four you will on
yourself
[Applause]
the man who understands violence
like this place you can't take that from
me
that can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily do you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]